we have been denied opportunities since
the beginning of time and still we
prevail
so i'm honored imagine
what we could do together rihanna had
the audience on their feet
at the 51st naacp image awards
the singer delivered a powerful speech
after accepting the president's award
saturday night
if there's anything that i've learned
is that we can only fix this world
together
we we can't do it divided i cannot
emphasize that enough
we can't let the desensitivity seep in
the if it's your problem then it's not
mine
it's a woman's problem it's a black
people
problem it's a poor people problem
rihanna was given the special
recognition for her achievement and work
in public service
how many of us in this room have
colleagues and partners and friends from
other races
sexes religions showing hands
when we're marching and protesting
and posting about the michael brown
juniors
and the tatiana jeffersons of the world
tell your friends to pull up people in
the crowd were cheering for the fenty
beauty including lizzo tracy ellis ross
and angela bassett
riri has been an outspoken advocate for
young people
around the world she even started her
own foundation
i always wanted to help that's always
been my
instinct it's been my nature and is the
way i was raised
and so you know those are traits that
have
come down from my grandparents clara and
lionel who
the clarinet foundation is named after
so
it's always been in me it's not one
thing that sparked it it just was
always something that i care to do a
philanthropist
a business entrepreneur fashion icon is
there anything this woman
can't do i mean let me think oh
we know release a new album you never
know i mean we'll just have to wait and
see
we've been waiting for the highly
anticipated r9 but riri has yet to
confirm a release date
fans went crazy when the singer posted
this photo with a caption
back in the stew the sound board also
read the neptunes which hints that she's
collaborating with pharrell williams
but that's not the only hint she's made
about r9
back in december she posted this video
of a dog jumping around with a caption
me listening to r9 by myself and
refusing to release it
et spoke to riri earlier this month and
she flat out admitted she loves messing
with her fans
dot dot dot re
ring my finger dot dot dot to be
continuous yeah that's r9 right there
but i love that
she claps on it too well that post on
instagram whenever you had the dog
barking like i'm listening
or none oh my god i like to antagonize
my fans a little bit
hateful well they antagonize me too oh
yeah so
they get it right back
you